I was when I first heard that you were
putting this movie together I had the
thought this isn't gonna be out for
quite a while take a long time to get
this together I was stunned by how
quickly you were able to turn zero dark
thirty around it's an incredibly
complicated story and the logistics
alone must be very daunting and how
quickly did you make this film
well we actually started shooting not
even a year from now it's a February
29th it hasn't been a year but we were
there was a kind of urgency I mean as a
story was unfolding the events were
unfolding Mark Boal who is also an
investigative reporter was reporting the
events and writing the screenplay and I
was in India going back and forth
between India and the Middle East trying
to prep locations while the story was
being written so it was kind of a
confluence of events were you working on
this story before Osama bin Laden was
even we were a different story it was
the first in assaulters into Tora Bora
2001 where they had Osama bin Laden in a
two square mile grid in Afghanistan and
then he slipped out the backdoor to
Pakistan I mean so that was that story
and then we were about two-thirds of the
way through that screenplay when may 1st
2011 happened and my first thought was
oh well now we have a last act and then
as Mark was reporting an ending we
didn't really or any was not as perfect
as that anyway so but once you kind of
get through the emotional part of you
know right now he's dead and that sort
of relived 9/11 but then realizing that
there was this intelligence you know
that all the work inside the
intelligence community and the hunt
itself became the movie now were you
worried that you're turning his story
around quickly obviously the quality did
not suffer in any way but were you
worried at the time we're getting this
out too quickly you know I thought
actually I think that would have been a
little bit paralyzing I didn't worry
about that what what was exciting to me
was the urgency and the kind of
timeliness of it and the fact that we
could be part of a conversation of
events that were unfolding and so it was
really like using a movie as almost a
way to report events even though I know
it's ten years compressed into two and a
half hours so it was definitely a
dramatization but at the same time
there was you know kind of resonance in
the timeliness of making this so quickly
well it's such a powerful topic that it
is it's inevitably been controversial
there's been controversy three senators
have come forward they've called the the
film factually inaccurate and they wrote
a letter they asked Sony to admit that
the film isn't real in every single
aspect which is itself causing a lot of
controversy yeah no question I have to
say that was extremely surprising I mean
I haven't actually heard about anything
like that happening since perhaps the
40s but but nonetheless you know once
you're kind of over the surprise of it
all we we have had a fair amount of
supporters as well like Leon Panetta who
is the director of the CIA during that
time say it was a very good movie and
that we basically got it right and
Senator Dodd Chris Dodd who's head of
the MPA and congresswoman Jane Harman
and all of whom have been real
supporters of the movie as well as
general McChrystal and some incredible
journalists like like David Ignatius
Mark Bowden who wrote a phenomenal book
called the finish which is about the
detainee program which is what was the
substance of the controversy and and
Roger Cohen in the New York Times just
day before yesterday so it has been you
know we have had a fair amount of
champions and we have had some
detractors so we were talking backstage
it's amazing the film Lincoln has had
controversy you've had people coming
forward and saying well no we feel like
Connecticut's being misrepresented and
how they they voted on the amendment and
you think it's been you know a hundred
and fifty years practically and people
are it that's getting people angry so
you'd think that it's inevitable that
there's going to be controversy well I
also think that it's it's accurate in
the way a movie can be accurate you know
it's not a documentary and so Kent I
mean it's it's ten years into two and a
half hours I mean I don't even know how
you would how you would you know in
other words it you had to dramatize it
you know it had to be you had to make
compressing compressions you had to do
find composite characters